what are you doing Josh
I wanted to love you Josh no can't trust
me
it's just it's just gonna be different
angles of Captain America's ass
he was eating Chad Chad's grocery list
Josh yo you're dead to me wait so
they're gonna update or not I don't know
[ __ ] Josh
how do you say oh you said piece of [ __ ]
I thought he said Pizza [ __ ] I do
every Pizza sometimes no he's a pizza
[ __ ] he only needs a surprise to [ __ ]
Josh welcome back to new rock stars
She-Hulk episode 7 teaches us how to up
on my stay through getting ghosted by
revealing a few men who aren't evil on
this show but trading them for a
sweetheart who totally is want to be
vampire saracen called it Josh just
wanted Jen's blood but you know I didn't
see a massive vibrating syringe so what
really happened that night holy [ __ ]
this is inside Marvel new rock stars
She-Hulk after show I'm Eric Voss with
me is Jessica Clemens nmt Hello friends
hi I'm going to kill Hot Josh he's dead
to me you I better not see him on the
street because I will fight you Josh you
like they were so happy together at the
beginning like why couldn't you be a
good man this is this is also not to be
confused with ugly Josh ugly Josh if
you're out there we're not gonna beat
you up only we're not talking about you
ugly Jeff talk about hot jobs just not
Josh
you know uh you gotta imagine even if
you are a secret member of the
intelligencia community and you that's
your plan is to get blood can't you just
look around at what you have on these
wonderful dates going uh you got your
nice French tuck in there getting some
tacos from LA's wonderful taco trucks
going to a drive-in movie and just
realize you know what what I have here
is pretty great and just throw that
syringe in a in a biodegradable safe
medical waste container uh and then just
move on with your life uh Josh Josh
look around look around how lucky you
are to be alive
to sing at you they only want to ruin
things also watch Josh have a previous
history
oh my God Watch Remember previous
history with like The Duel of our lemon
he's like I lost my mom and it's all
your cousin's fault so I'm gonna take my
freaking anger out on you my mom's car
got turned into a bunch of gloves
no I'm mad you got shot on my mom I
think the hardest part for me to accept
is that people this handsome can can
still be this off oh my God just imagine
how beautiful people yeah they're a
little vain they're maroon 5S
do you think the average Beauty like
he's too much of a Chad to be an incel
wouldn't you say no pretty people are
mean people yeah this is why I don't
make new friends
yeah no one everyone will disappoint you
at some point let's go through what
happened this episode because it did
seem like a sleeper of an episode but
there's some parts of it that I really
enjoyed and really appreciated uh even
if this show should not promise
Daredevil at the ending of one episode
come on
and we're still gonna be like why
Daredevils tendency in the finale it's
like and I'm never gonna they're never
gonna bring them in at this point and
it's so funny now it's just gone over to
me I'm like I'm going mad I'm going
crazy we saw that hat box which with
Daredevil's mask in it right I wouldn't
know that wasn't a mass elucidation no
it happened but uh anyway okay so
episode seven it starts with a very uh
smitten blushing gin readying herself
for a date with Josh I love this opening
sequence so much of the music uh I I
love how it was shot the tone of it she
was so happy even though we knew what
was coming oh my God uh before her first
stage in each string cheese learning
nothing apparently unaffected by Reed
Richard's death the Multiverse of
Madness I don't think I can go anywhere
near string cheese after that but good
on you Jen I thought it was interesting
that she does a shot now I get it liquid
courage it does look like it's in the
middle of the afternoon if am I too uh
Puritan to judge Jin's drinking on the
show because she drinks so much on this
show
I mean I mean she got a stressful life
man she's a lawyer I'd be drinking too
also I guess it's like I think they're
trying to emphasize like you're in your
early 30s and I'm not yet 30 but
I think I drink just as much I think I'm
in my early 30s and I don't like sit
down by myself and pour a shot of
whiskey before it dates but I guess some
people do you are in love and you are
not alone and you don't have to deal
with you guys that's what single people
do Eric
all right okay I won't judge it I just
like I grew up in a household with a lot
of heavy drinking and I'm still
traumatized by it so whenever I just see
people drink straight Booze episode
after episode and it's unaddressed maybe
this is like an Ally McBeal thing like
they're getting hammered on Ally McBeal
cheers they're literally sitting around
and then George winch is like all right
uh eight down here I go pulls out his
keys and walks out the bar door and no
one bats an eye at that so this is just
my um delicate uh sensibilities being
triggered here don't mind it's all good
don't mind me anyway so after three
adorable dates with Josh she wakes up to
find him gone and she texts him
something that like it's one of the
sweetest texts to send or receive that
was fun I can't stop smiling my heart
melted when she sent that right oh my
God I would I would kill to get a text
like that from Tatiana are you kidding
me are you kidding me that's the hardest
thing I think I'm struggling with on the
show obviously there's you know a few
different things we're struggling with
but the idea that so many people are so
mean to Tatiana maslani it's Tatiana
seriously beautiful she's one of the
sweetest kindest people to go on a date
with and she makes money like this is a
catch what are you doing like that's why
I'm saying Josh I don't care what
internet forums you're on realize what
date you're on right now and how much of
a catch you have and just let it go
seriously Let It Go I would love to be a
bronze trophy husband for uh Tatiana
maslani lawyer
um just uh you will be empty
she's out there and this sends the fact
that she doesn't get a response since
Jen's spiraling waiting for a response a
place that I think we have all been
before you guys can say I'm in love
right now and I am I am I'm very very
lucky and fortunate but there have been
many many years of my life my entire 20s
my entire 20s for the most part I was
sitting staring at my phone waiting for
hours spots and that never ever came and
thank God I did it it's been my entire
life
um to this day
um so you need to delete those numbers
we will be your goofy uh therapy group
of villains that will tell you delete it
this episode read me like a book and so
it's hard for me to even comment on it
I'm hurting I see I see let's keep going
I feel it so Nikki drops that Jen has
been nominated for female lawyer of the
year which feels like it's gonna be
something setting up next episode right
we've seen some footage and trailers
where she's getting uh out at an event
on a red carpet I feel like that's you
never yeah you never know though we got
set up for Daredevil and it's been two
episodes
it's too early it's too early for that
right now
um but uh it makes me wonder what are
the other female lawyers do you think
Mal was jealous he thinks somewhere in
New York Jerry Hogarth is like God damn
it 100 100 again
so Jen tries to distract herself with
some yoga she watches some Miss Piggy
Pride open prison bars so the great
Muppet Caper uh still no response from
Josh though Emil blonsky's parole
officer Chuck says blonsky's modern chip
malfunction he's just eating all the
break room desserts I love that guys on
a mission for some sweets but um he
asked Jen to accompany him to blonsky's
Ranch because he's afraid of abomination
who wouldn't be uh they find you feel
like if it was Abomination running amok
you would hear about it he wouldn't just
be in the woods up state or not even
Upstate just north of L.A but hey all
kinds of creepy [ __ ] can happen North
and L.A just watch nope you know that's
a great amazing movie chess did such a
fun breakdown of that on our Channel go
go watch that
um but um they find Blonsky there he's
chilling they fix the chip Jen's priest
gets wrecked by some dopes uh dueling
low-level super villains attending
blotsky's uh Retreat to redeem
themselves they end up being really
swell dudes there's uh El Aguila AKA
Alejandro Montoya this is a real guy in
the comics he's a spot he's a
swashbuckling Spaniard not a matador
despite doing some light matadorian in
college
um in the comics he's actually a mutant
who does release bioelectricity like so
I would love to see more of that he's
part of the heroes for higher comics
with our man Power Man and Iron Fist uh
there's also man bull who's a daredevil
villain who was injected with a
mutagenic serum based on bull enzymes uh
we literally spent a solid minute of our
own time just watching a character
wander around looking for cell service
oh my God I can't believe that was just
a chunk of this episode
doing nothing okay but when you say it
like that when you say it like that it
does sound ridiculous hey they were
showcasing blonde
beautiful property look how well he's
doing
what a piece of land oh my god do you
know how much that is in California in
California they're out of their mind
those wives were rich rich yeah you have
to be a king you have to be like a
secret King in California to own that
much land are you kidding me because
he's not a he's not a farmer he's not
he's not a Rancher yeah there was some
chickens yeah just a few chickens a
handful of what princess silk feathers
that's right
um so she finally went into signal and
blonsky's Wood lodge where we meet more
Retreat attendees including porcupine
who's an Ant-Man villain with some uh
amazing razor tipped quills that pop off
of a suit that do all kinds of stuff we
didn't get to see any of that he was
just a guy in a smelly sweaty suit
that's my favorite part that was my
favorite part that was um literally my
favorite part of the time I was so
anxious that like he was going to prick
Jen's skin and like cause her to bleed
but I was like oh no he's just a smelly
man he's just a smelly guy see when they
check out the mask I thought it was
gonna be like a really well known
celebrity I thought it was gonna be like
Seth Rogen
[Music]
it's me it's not but I love this guy
it's a guy that on IMDb it's his one and
only acting credit so this might be his
first ever role which I was kind of like
I was kind of getting it seemed like
improv a little bit for him so I was
like and he's really good at playing
this role so I was like go play yourself
do you baby he was a lot of fun
um there's also this weirdo named
saracen who's actually a Punisher
villain in the comics he's just kind of
like an assassin but here he claims to
be a vampire and I think he might be
because he didn't correctly predict that
Josh wanted Jen's blood I think there's
more to that but then lastly wrecker the
leader of the wrecking crew from episode
3 who gen hilariously previously ons to
remind us about I really really enjoyed
that like that was one example of like I
I think I actually did need that for a
second I'm like wait is that the
magician or is that whatever dates like
and I watched a show for work and I
still didn't remember who this guy was
he looked his hair was up in a ponytail
yeah his errors up in a ponytail and I
thought the same thing too I was like oh
[ __ ] who is that I was like
uh Jen throws him across the room we
actually finally see Jen Hulk and D Hulk
a few times this episode I really like
that uh I like that like they they her
running across the room like doing this
kind of growing as she ran I thought
that was a lot of a lot of fun
um but she ends up joining the circle
the guy's helper accept that Josh uh
indeed did Ghost her and shin gives us
meaningful admission about how being
She-Hulk is in a lot of ways harder than
being Jen because it makes a
disappointment of a rejection feel even
worse I really really appreciated this
like this is uh just an example of
everyone out there when the grass is
greener even if you get everything you
ever wanted the anxiety is still there
in some ways the anxiety is more vicious
and like I feel like this is a really
great illustration to how like you know
just a lot of everybody does this like
Everyone likes to put on a certain
facade that they want people to see it's
like yeah this is the cool version of me
but then like you have like the the real
you that's like you know more insecure
and like more like you know more
vulnerable and like she wants people to
accept her for her rather than like the
more flashier and um you know just
cooler looking side of her which I can
totally relate to for sure this is the
first time though that she said Jen is
great and I was like
she's recognizing I was like she's
recognized and she notices that she's
actually the best thing that's ever
walked this Earth seriously I love
she-hole Yeah it reminded me of that
moment in no way home where Toby just
tells Andrew like you are amazing right
that's okay yes you could be amazing
um you know this is like a thing I was
doing a lot of things about this when I
was walking Darla this morning
um the uh this is like a thing that
you're seeing more and more in TV shows
written by writers of a certain
generation and now finally we're having
Millennial showrunners I think a couple
years ago we were just finishing off
like the Gen X generation being the show
Runners like yeah you're just sweet and
your Shonda Rhimes your Dan Harmon doing
me wrong those people are still like
very very powerful in this industry
um but like now we're starting to have a
generation of people who are a bit
younger like Justin Roiland is taking
over his own shows and now you have like
Jessica gow is taking over this show
um and you see like this different thing
where I think in the Gen X generation
you had characters telling other
characters what they needed to hear and
giving that tough love yes in this
generation we're now having people who
are just monologuing and discovering it
themselves so we have this moment in
She-Hulk the bear had a whole episode
where I think it's like one of the
better or the best episode of That
season the the one camera shot there
yeah there's that is that the same
episode of where he just I think the
episode after that is where the first
half of it is him just going to AAA and
just like oh unloading everything wrong
with him and like we need that like
characters are emotions I think
Millennials are so complicated and
layered and confusing we just need a
moment just to vent everything that's
going on with us right now I think
Bojack had a moment like this where he
was at the funeral home that whole
episode and he's just like running he's
just kind of unpacking oh and I think
like for for uh viewers of a certain age
this is very uh therapeutic for us to
watch characters go this even if it it's
there's a debate here does this make
good television I would say yes because
I think that is the point of content is
to help us like to reflect ourselves
back to us and help us see ourselves
through a different light but it doesn't
necessarily make for the most active
storytelling I'll admit that uh I would
love like the classic approach to
storytelling is to find a way for the
character to discover this actively
through like action through not
necessarily like be fighting or or like
shooting or a car chase but like through
like active choices in their lives and I
think it would be interesting to explore
Jin's like cell phone addiction or her
addiction to a response you know in a
text exchange uh rather than just people
explaining it to her but I don't know
that might just be what people need
right now I think it is I also think it
gave me it's the same feeling I got with
one division which I think what made one
division a really good show was like me
recognizing where Wanda is and
recognizing like I would be going
through the same exact situation I
understand the feelings and that I think
the show does a really good job of doing
that and I don't think they're trying to
cater to one audience I think they're
overarching they like this is Jen and
you guys are also Jen we're also dealing
with this anyone that feels like they
have to have two different personalities
or just have to like cheer for two
different people they can resin like
this can resonate with them and so I
think for the storytelling wise this
makes me this is like a book to me it
made me feel yeah but this is also like
something I really needed to hear this
week and so like this entire episode was
like me watching it and also growing and
learning with it so I genuinely love it
as like just storytelling wise perfect
for a young woman almost in her 30s
perfect for me and I I don't know that
was just me that was me I I'm obsessed
with this episode probably my favorite
episode and I like it I really enjoyed
this episode myself like this like I
just like when
um media can really connect with The
Human Experience a lot yeah and like
this episode like really did that and
like I I know like a lot of like like
just just said I know a lot of women
could probably relate to a lot of what's
going on in this episode out and like
you know just you know I just I just I
love how the show is just like
commentary on toxic masculinity like
it's just it's so great to me and I
really enjoyed how like the villains
were the actual good guys it's like hey
we're like we're villains but we're not
monsters you know like we're we're
trying to listen to you and give you
good advice
um actually bad if they're actually bad
I will be so
I I will rage I can't have man bull be
bad now like
agreed agree don't disappoint us please
but I I totally agree I think the show
has never felt more confident in who Jen
and who She-Hulk are as people than in
that whole monologue she talked about
how how hard it is to be Shield
um and how people don't necessarily
desire She-Hulk I I thought that was
like great I could use more of that
throughout the season but I'm glad we
finally got there in this episode
um oh by the way I did this kind of like
loose analysis of what um what Gen X
showrunners are like and what Millennial
show Runners are right we still have to
see what gen Z showrunners are gonna
look like my expectation is it's going
to be chaos
it's gonna be a lot of dancing for no
reason but it's gonna also be hilarious
because gen Z is one of those oh it's
gonna be the best yeah
no they're not this is me oh funny this
is me being jealous of the Gen Z years
on Tick Tock that are genuinely very
funny I'm like no you're not funny no
you're not I went to school for this and
you naturally are so gifted like I have
a joke it's literally just gonna be yeah
the director saying like I don't know
who Obama is [ __ ] this I'm leaving I'm
bored with this and walk out bye
Obama is I just find it I'm now at the
generation where like Keke Palmer does
interviews that she doesn't know what
things are and I'm like I love her so
there is no before Kiki Palmer let the
past die and I'm with you I love her so
at least she's and she's also honest
when she didn't know who the president
was
though when they showed her like an
image of the president she was like I'll
be honest I don't know who that is
okay so back to this episode the guy's
convinced Jen to delete Josh's number uh
she's hurting for the urine she says
goodbye to the guys makes her way back
to LA and I recognize that past that
said Malibu Canyon right on your way to
the PCH I've taken that drive before
it's a beautiful drive beautiful drive
uh but if there's a rain careful watch
out for those Rock slides because
everyone takes that pass when it rains
and then cars get crashed um the final
scene rewinds the clock to three nights
earlier revealing Josh is copying the
data on Jen's phone and then takes a
photo of her while she sleeps and then
he texts to Hulk King emojis of a needle
a test tube and a thumbs up we did
suspect last week that Josh was too good
to be true and probably working for the
intelligencia but I still have questions
about what exactly happened in this
final scene and I want to dig into it a
bit more I just need you guys to tell me
that I'm crazy
um but see if you want to hit us with
that merch plug yeah man guys be sure to
head on over to new rockstarsmerch.com
to grab our latest Obsession shirt Lady
Justice inspired by She-Hulk attorney at
law the show series the shirt is limited
edition and when you purchase it you
unlock the ability to get a custom shout
out that will appear right here on
inside Marvel so support this Channel
and check out all of our awesome merch
options over at newrockstarsmerch.com
today okey doke what's our question from
episode seven when and how did Josh
steal Jen's blood how did he get it yeah
I mean we assume he did based off of the
text he said but we don't actually see
him steal it or even close syringe again
if you don't want to show like a sleepy
person get like syringed out that that's
kind of gross and kind of creepy
um but like you would think like you'd
just see him close that case or walk off
with that case to imply it yeah I mean
that guy his clothes fits so well there
was no big bulky a vibranium syringe
sticking out anywhere yeah
um has he not done it yet maybe just by
copying Jen's phone he'll be able to get
it later I might be completely crazy but
when General's over in bed after her
night with Josh her back is exposed and
you can see two dark spots on her
shoulder might just be moles that's what
I was assuming his molds but the episode
opens with Jen getting out of the shower
her back was exposed there too I went
back to check don't think we see them
it's a little out of focus the
reflection on the mirror is a bit hazy
from the steam but I did go back to
check an uncomfortable amount of photos
of Tatiana maslani enough to guarantee
me a lifelong registry on the
intelligency of mailing list I'm just
kidding I'm just kidding I just looked
at these recent red carpet appearance at
the She-Hulk Premiere in August which
also made me feel a little uncomfortable
the fact that I was doing that at all
but in her awesome outfit her shoulders
were exposed and it she definitely does
not have those
she does not and so either either while
they're shooting She-Hulk she had the
bowls and then she had it removed or
whatever I don't think so I think there
might be something there maybe those
moles were actually the spots where Josh
inserted the needle it was saracen's
teeth I'm just kidding
he showed up
I think Josh could have gotten the blood
before we saw him getting dressed maybe
return the case to his car came back in
the house to copy Jen's phone and then
Jen you know she'd have to be sleeping
pretty heavily I mean he could have
thrown in his pocket
um
you can't carry a loose syringe oh no
you take the top okay first off I'm sure
they have like a weird like here's the
giant needle thing let's put it into
this let's transfer it into a different
little smack up
giant needle being shoved in your pocket
Eric it was already the case it was it a
case I I looked his pockets were like
you could tell if someone has their
phone in their pocket uh he didn't have
anything in his pocket oh like imagine
like maybe flat imagine he just like he
just taped it to his he was like Hey
listen I have a weird fetish I like
needles nearby don't even remember
no no no no
you are a no we're leaving it in empty
that was
both of you guys added yourself as
creeps today you you staring at her at
her shoulder on different red carpets
you're like Tatiana Maslany naked I was
just looking for those balls
it orphanage
[Music]
I swear I promise this is for academic
research yeah I don't I'm just kind of
wondering when Josh was able to do this
has he done it yet based on saracen
being the one to call this out I'm also
wondering if to Mt you might be right we
got a little pocket Theory here that
Josh could be a vampire uh but either
way this confirms that Josh is working
for the Intelligentsia but now it
appears that the wrecker is retired from
whatever that operation was because I
assumed that they were trying to get the
blood for the intelligence either the
same needle so do you think record and
perhaps some other members of The
Wrecking Crew or some other members of
this Therapy Group might help Jen fight
back against the Intelligentsia and
should we still expect a Hulk melee in
the finale Hulk versus Hulk I think that
the other people in The Retreat will
help her I think the wrecker is still up
to no good because he was the one that
initiated deleting Josh's phone number
from her phone and was like delete it
delete it delete it and I think he was
like helping get rid of evidence so I
don't think
he's actually helpful I
had to know good but I'm very scared
like that whole wrecker reveal was very
surprising I was like oh my God you were
here like why
why um so yeah I don't trust the wrecker
100 but like yeah I do think that the
advice that they gave her was like from
the heart they were I think they're
genuinely good great guys but that are
just working a job probably for the
intelligency it's like hey we were just
hired to do this no hard feelings you're
really nice
but yeah yeah it's not not making me
wonder how many things in Jen's life are
part of this conspiracy it kind of like
the fact that Josh at the wedding was
also a bad guy wrecker is now showing up
at the therapy session we had Todd show
up at her Law Firm like all these dudes
keep reappearing and it's like it can't
at this point the show is saying no it
was not just coincidence no it's just
it's not happenstance they are all part
of the intelligenceia trying to steal
her blood so like how deep does this go
or how high does it go it feels like
every man in her life is trying to steal
her blood including Mr Holloway
including the bartender including all
the guys who have brought her drinks
including every guy she's been on a date
with pug pug are you part of it no no
he's the only good man in this world
pug and Jonathan both are not pug and
Jonathan are good boys
um Jonathan's the gross dog
they're both good boys yeah
um I did Pitch I think in the breakdown
where um it does feel like it is
everybody because they even mentioned
the gala uh the um the scla thing that
she's been nominated female lawyer of
the year and we saw in the trailer that
that's the same Gala event that she's at
which we also think right that that's
the same event where the people with the
weapon that has those like high
frequency weapons are at yeah so it's
like is it all just a setup oh is it all
just to set up every even her being
nominated for female lawyer of the year
is also a setup like
it's it was never this intense like if
it was such a setup why haven't you just
like kidnapped her and killed her yes
like if you have this much control over
her life yes she was drunk in pretty
vulnerable many times you could have
kidnapped and killed her and no what
about it your one fail was The Wrecking
Crew so yeah you guys could have done
better I'm sure I'm sure you did not
need to go this length of going through
like millions of different men tricking
her at weddings setting up her a wedding
setting up these things like you did not
need to go through all of that but they
did it was very Three Stooges going on
three dates where the first one ends in
a handshake like no I'm gonna play the
long game he said I'm in it to win it
you could have just paid a bike
messenger to come by and like run into
her and be like Oh I'm sorry
oops let me help you up
[Applause]
[Music]
no I need to check your blood make sure
you're fine no bruises
you could have paid off her doctor like
Jim has to go to a physical the grand
takes the blood she goes okay well I
think they had her blood from the last
episode because it was all about like
Jen but not Shield but it's so injury I
don't know I I think maybe next episode
we'll get more leeway into like how her
blood actually works because I was like
you guys have a lot of information on
Jen's actual blood and DNA why are you
stealing her blood as Jen when she's
asleep will it still be she-hulk's blood
I don't I mean there's something really
special about her blood that makes it
easy to synthesize gamma radiation so
like at the very least even though she's
not in Shield form that could be a huge
huge Plus for whoever needs her blood
and I think that like it doesn't really
because like um Bruce was in Bruce form
and his blood changed her to Shield so
like I think it doesn't matter if she's
in um yeah that's what I'm wondering
what they stole before because on the
cameras it was all of Jen's body like it
was all Jen's like in that energy but
all of her yeah all of her vitals and I
was like so you have it isn't that
enough and they're like no we need the
physical cut maybe they just do you need
a physical object what'd you say about
us I'm I'm telling you guys vampires
that's the only explanation at this
point can you have to drink this stuff
after their own with it sure can you
imagine when the vampires get her blood
it's it's the intelligencia versus the
vampires trying to get she holds blood
but no I honestly do feel like the
series is gonna end with the Hulk versus
Hulk battle and like Todd is gonna use
that blood to become the Hulk that he
was obsessed with on the date and uh he
just he just really wants to be super
powered and I feel like that's why maybe
he hangs around the superpower division
of the um the lawyer office and uh maybe
like that's why that's how he
potentially knows all these uh super
villains from blonsky's
um little Retreat he's like hey I just
I'm obsessed with superhuman people
um but I don't know what we'll see I
think you're right I think ultimately
this show has done
um many things that I've enjoyed one
thing is keeping expectations very low
in terms of whether things are gonna
make sense because they're they're uh
tactics so far has been to just like
when things don't make sense just have
Tatiana maslani look at the camera and
make fun of it but it's fine like I I've
honestly like there have been other
Disney Plus shows we've covered Marvel
where I like I have like uh I've really
enjoy them and then one episode comes
out I'm like what happened what happened
how why am I confused right now I was I
thought they were I thought it was all
well I thought they I thought this was
gonna come together perfectly and then
uh but now with this show I'm just kind
of like whatever like it's fun I mean go
off I don't care all right so we have a
couple more questions we want to talk
about before we get to next episode but
first sleep is important and here at new
rockstars We Trust Helix to protect our
sleep with the best mattresses in the
world I have a helix mattress as does MT
and recently producer Zach producer John
also got Helix mattresses Helix sleep is
a quiz that takes us two minutes to
complete and matches your body type and
your sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you everybody's unique and
Helix knows that so they have several
different mattress models to choose from
they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattress is great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot mattress is
great for spinal alignment to prevent
morning aches and pains even a helix
plus mattress for those plus side
sleepers out there producer Zach took
the quiz the Helix quiz and was matched
to the midnight Luxe mattress because
he's a side sleeper that needed a softer
mattress and now he doesn't wake up with
a sore shoulder or neck like he did with
the other mattresses just go to
helixsleep.com inside Marvel take their
two minute sleep quiz and they'll match
you to a customized mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life
they have a 10 year warranty and you get
to try it out for 100 nights risk-free
Helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helixsleep.com inside
Marvel and fellas we all want to perform
a little magic in the bedroom but
sometimes you need more than just a
sling ring you need a little blue that's
right this episode is also brought to
you by bluetooth confidence can take you
far in life but it can also help in the
bedroom that's where Bluetooth comes in
Bluetooth is a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis but
tablets and at a fraction of the cost
you can take them anytime day or night
you can plan ahead be ready for whenever
an opportunity arises the process is
simple sign up at bluetoo.com consult
with one of their licensed medical
providers and once you're approved
you'll receive your prescription within
days and it's all done online no
business to the doctor his office no
awkward conversations no wait in line at
the pharmacy Bluetooth tablets are made
in the USA and prepared and shipped
direct to your door in a discrete
package so if you could benefit from
some extra competence when it's time to
perform Bluetooth can help and we've got
a special deal for our listeners and
fans and viewers try Bluetooth free when
you use our promo code Marvel at
checkout just pay the five dollars in
shipping that's bluetooth.com promo code
Marvel to receive your first month free
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank Bluetooth for sponsoring this show
all right let's talk about our man
saracen could saracen be connected to
Blade do we think he actually is a
vampire does he know a vampire what's
his deal yes
yes yes I I want okay so what I want I
want him to be a vampire I absolutely
want him to be a vampire and I do want
him to come in contact with blade
because there is an issue where I think
it is Blade's issue where he does go up
against uh Saras Saras and sarasan I
read it as soraken which is not how you
say it
so so
welcome
and he shoots out where they go up
against each other and it's so badass
and so I would love to see that but that
version of him is like like a demon
spirit with eye sewn shut and lip sewn
shut definitely not what we saw in
She-Hulk but maybe that's like a human
form of him damn it boss oh no he's gone
no yes I know that in she-hulky is like
a human so maybe this is him in like
human form and he can transfer to being
um a spirit but I also I just don't want
what I don't want is him to be like yes
I am this demon monster and then be like
just a normal human guy that has seen
that human monster like hell we got
Johnny Blaze out of Donnie Blaze I don't
I like I don't want that I don't want
that name well
um yeah no I I think I definitely feel
like this is going to be like this was
meant to be a blade tease because uh
like you said like he um
like two or three appearances in the
Marvel Comics and um he he then those
are all blade comics and um apparently
he's like one of the oldest vampires on
the planet which is like super crazy
um and yeah I definitely feel like this
was an intentional like like the first
um blade reference that we got since
eternals so I'm super excited also a
creature that lives under the Vatican is
uh really cool to me
under the Vatican and historically
because you know they have a few of them
they
in everywhere yeah
um all right next question are we ever
gonna learn why why Titania smashed into
the courtroom
why would you ask me that why would you
even ask
I hope so I hope to God we do because
that is still unanswered are we no are
we
I'm not okay I love this show before I
say anything I love this show you guys
do not take this the wrong way we
haven't seen LeapFrog yet we haven't
seen Daredevil I know we've got two
episodes left do you think we're gonna
somehow squeeze what Titania broke in
that courtroom in those two episodes
maybe because like we do know from like
um the the back audio of like that court
trial that like
um there was like an accident like a
construction accident or something that
um that happened and like maybe Titania
was trying to advocate for um the
absorbing man because like they we know
that they date in the comics so like
maybe Daredevil comes and he's like
linked to the whole like Scandal that
what they were talking about before she
smashed in and like I think that maybe
that whole Daredevil Arc could be like
how they end the series and like how
they wrap everything up
um but I don't know who knows so they
there's stuff from the trailer that they
haven't talked about yet which is yes
the gala we still haven't seen the gala
so she could have also involvement in
that but we also there's a b-roll where
they're doing like behind the scenes and
we see Titania dancing at the same at
the retreat at uh yeah
haven't so I think we're gonna go back
to the treat and maybe we'll get some
information there but also remember how
we in the trailer got like that 80s tape
kind of recording of Bruce and Jen that
oh yeah we're not gonna get that I don't
think either so it's like you don't know
how many times I have to re-watch the
trailers to be like have we seen this
before and then I'm like we're never
gonna see this I think this was only
made for the trailer
what a really really weird shot that
they put in that trailer oh I forgot
about that that's so insane oh my God
okay so yeah let's let's try to make
some final predictions for these next
two episodes we gotta have Daredevil and
LeapFrog next week hopefully I need the
Frog Squad to activate I've got my hat
after ready I'm ready to go I need my
strong man in my life
um but yeah I think that um please this
next episode has to we only have two
episodes so like we have to get this
double next episode okay the thing is if
you don't put them in next episode you
can't force that in like the last
episode has to be like an hour long if
you're gonna put in LeapFrog a daredevil
the resolution for Titania the gala
stuff like I need the intelligencia full
thing like is the leadership like I just
need you gotta do it you have to start
next episode 100 you cannot start in the
last one stop screwing around
this episode I was like here it is we're
gonna get everything started talking
about and then I went well
we're in therapy
I needed it and you know what sometimes
we need that sometimes it's exactly what
we need and we can't delay it we can't
stop it it was good to see men in
therapy for once for once in their dang
lives men in therapy and we'll never go
again
we did that I already tried that didn't
work punch in a hole in my wall did
that's the real therapy
because on the other side of that hole
in the wall hey you know what you find
you find a donut and that donut is yummy
it's true hey that's it for this episode
of inside Marvel Jessica's breakdown is
coming tomorrow of all the details he
missed in the episode uh follow me at EA
boss follow Jessica at Lulu underscore
Clemons follow Mt at masterton Mitch
subscribe to inside Marvel wherever you
get your podcast subscribe to new
rockstars here on YouTube thank you so
much for watching bye everybody later
thank you
foreign